jan seit neun monaten lief der prozess
gegen den ehemaligen kz-wachmann bruno
de ihm wird beihilfe zum mord in 5230
menschen vorgeworfen
heute wurde das urteil gefällt
urteilsverkündung in hamburg am 45
prozesstag gegen den ehemaligen
kz-wachmann bruno dts der 93 jährige
wurde wegen beihilfe zum mord in 5320
fällen und wegen der beihilfe zum
versuchten mord in einem fall zu zwei
jahren haft auf bewährung verurteilt
die vorsitzende richterin anne meyer
köring sprach den mann schuldig an den
tausendfachen morden beteiligt gewesen
zu sein
im konzentrationslager stutthof bei
danzig soll bruno de als ss wachmann
zwischen dem 9
august 1944 und dem 26 april 1945 die
heimtückische und grausame tötung
insbesondere jüdischer häftlinge
unterstützt haben
laut verteidiger von bruno de habe der
angeklagte bei beginn seines dienstes
1944 geglaubt stoff sein lager für
politische häftlinge
insofern habe er als 17-jähriger nicht
erkennen können dass der befehl zum
wachdienst dort von vornherein
verbrecherisch war
all diese gräueltaten will der
angeklagte nicht gesehen haben es fällt
schwer das zu glauben auch von dem
vernichtungslager auschwitz will der
ehemalige ss wachmann bruno dts nach
eigener aussage nichts gewusst haben
über die massen transporte von stufen
nach auschwitz sei unter den wachleuten
nicht besprochen worden sagte der
angeklagte am 21 prozesstag vor dem
hamburger landgericht
seit einem dreiviertel jahr verhandelt
die jugendkammer am landgericht gegen
den ehemaligen wachmann mit dem urteil
geht das mammut verfahren gegen bruno de
das am 17 oktober 2009 10 begann nun zu
ende
mandanten der nebenklage äußerten
ausdrücklich den wunsch dass bruno den
nicht inhaftiert werde und sprachen sich
für eine bewährungsstrafe aus am
vorletzten prozesstag hatte sich bruno
de in seinem schlusswort bei den opfern
und ihren angehörigen entschuldigt
er bezeichnete dabei das geschehen in
dem konzentrationslager als eine hölle
des wahnsinns gleichzeitig aber
vermieter erneut eine bekenntnis der
mitschuld an den taten in dem lager und
betonte er hätte sich niemals freiwillig
zur ss gemeldet
und der historiker michael wolffsohn ist
mir jetzt live zugeschaltet guten abend
herr wolffsohn
wie kommt es denn zu einem solchen
milden urteil ihrer meinung nach gute
frage aber die antwort ist ziemlich klar
wir haben rechtliche formalitäten zu
berücksichtigen und damit sogar den kern
des problems das recht kann diese
unrechts daten zu verbrechen nicht
wirklich ahnten das können wir nicht nur
vom heutigen urteil sondern von vielen
früheren also hier steht das urteil ist
die strafe in keinem realistischen
verhältnis zu der tat
und wie ordnen sie das urteil ein
ich will noch ergänzen
bevor ich's einordne einen prozess gegen
einen 93 jährigen mann vor der
jugendstrafkammer warum
jugendstrafkammer weil der mann der
heute
verurteilt wurde damals 17 jahre alt
gewesen ist aber auch hier 93 17
das ist alles völlig unrealistisch in
bezug auf das was passiert ist mit
anderen worten man versucht in ein
rechtssystem das natürlich nicht von
hier auf jetzt verändert werden kann
diesen fall hinein zu pressen das urteil
ist einfach absurd und der angeklagte
betonte ja auch während der verhandlung
dass er nicht freiwillig kz wärter wurde
was sagen sie zu dieser erklärung ist
das realistisch dass man ja gezwungen
wurde beim holocaust mitzumachen
es ist ein unterschied ob man gezwungen
wurde zum holocaust holocaust bei zu
nehmen oder in ein bestimmtes ss wachen
moment also kurzum es ist durchaus
glaubwürdig und von fall zu fall
nachzuprüfen ich kann keine allgemeine
antwort hierauf geben
nur wer sich ist zu ss wer sich bei der
ss befand war sicherlich mehr motiviert
als jeder normale wehrpflicht punkt 1
um zwei mann wusste natürlich nicht
woher wohin man kommt also kurzum gibt
es keine von außen jedenfalls konkrete
antwort aber das sieht nach drückeberger
rey aus auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite ist eine reihe zu erkennen
und der täter hat sich sozusagen ein
schuldig aber was heißt entschuldigung
an den ort von über 5.000 menschen wie
auch immer beteiligt gewesen zu sein und
dann zu sagen entschuldigung kann
jemanden auf den schuhen getreten wäre
das auch so